[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alain-dominique 18 jours après le
passage de l'ouragan maria la population
tente de reprendre ses habitudes
une longue file d'attenté s'étire sur le
trottoir devant le plus grand
supermarché de roseaux l'établissement
devrait ouvrir dans deux ans c'est l'un
des premiers magasins à réouvrir ses
portes après le passage de maria et tout
le monde ici est contente de pouvoir
enfin se ravitaillait après des jours de
pénurie passé quasiment sans eau et sans
nourriture
normalement les portes des supermarchés
sont ouverts dès on peut entrer mais
c'est différent après l'ouragan parce
que beaucoup de magasins ont été
dépouillés les gens sont entrés pour
voler des choses d'autres magasins ont
été pillés bêtement parce que les gens
ont cassé ces établissements donc peu de
supermarchés sont suffisamment stocker
pour ouvrir
l intérieur supermarché il bien garni
pourtant ils avaient été endommagés par
le cyclone est complètement vidée par
les pillards
aujourd'hui c'est une véritable caverne
d'ali baba avec plus de 300 travailleurs
ce magasin et ses filières sont le
deuxième employeur à la dominique après
le gouvernement
le propriétaire gisèle à stéphane a fait
de son mieux pour ouvrir son
établissement aussi vite que possible
pour reprendre aux besoins de la
population et assurer l'activité de ses
salariés
une entreprise fermée pendant 17 jours
c'est catastrophique du point de vue
commercial
et c'est catastrophique pour le public
car il n'y a pas d'accès à la nourriture
personne n'a été licencié quelques
salariés ont dû quitter l'île parce
qu'ils n'ont plus de maison ou qu'il
faut qu'ils se mettent en sécurité
les policiers font leurs courses avant
le grand public car ils doivent assurer
la sécurité des lieux pendant les heures
d'ouverture
il n'y a pas de police est dehors
pas de policiers à l'extérieur je ne
pense pas
après deux heures d'attenté les clients
peuvent enfin entrer les personnes âgées
d'abord ensuite c'est par vingtaines que
les autres et clients y accède par une
petite porte la direction veut empêcher
tout débordement par la foule qui
s'impatientent
[Musique]
dont les rues de la capitale recouverte
d'une poussière épaisse les habitants
sont obligés de porter des masques
[Musique]
ici la compagnie d'électricité se
pressent pour raccorder les
consommateurs privés de courant depuis
près de trois semaines
mais tout le monde ne sera pas connecté
les branchements doivent être vérifiées
dans chaque maison par la compagnie et
seuls ceux qui sont aux normes seront
raccordés les autres doivent d'abord
réparer leur installation à leur frein
les files d'attentes devant les stations
de services deviennent moins longue
l'approvisionnement en carburant et en
gaz domestique et plus régulier
malgré les dégâts structurels qu'ont
subis les stations de service les cuves
et les pompes sont aux manches et les
clients peuvent faire le plein
c'est du n'importe quoi il ya toujours
de longues files d'attenté
on attend il faut être patient
en effet la vie reprend ses droits les
dom unités se reconstruise comme ils
peuvent le bruit des marteaux raison de
partout dans les petits quartiers les
habitants qui n'ont pas d'assurance et
qui ont tout perdu commence le nettoyage
et la reconstruction
les charpentiers trouvent du travail
chez les sinistrés qui hante encore les
moyens financiers de les embaucher
un été brûlant taper
avec
amazon
[Musique]
mais à la dominique le chômage
commencent à impacter la population du
tourisme est l'un des moteurs de
l'économie
25% de la population active travaillent
dans ce secteur cent vingt cinq types de
logements touristiques sont répertoriés
tous ont subi des dégâts considérables
voici ce qui reste de trois hôtels
situés au sud de roseaux camps sont en
fait des dominicains jouissait d'une
bonne réputation auprès d'une clientèle
adepte de plongée sous-marine à tout
comme un corps edge total située juste à
côté
ces hôtels doivent être complètement
reconstruits
c'est également des cadres f green qui
accueillait une clientèle variée l'hôtel
était surtout réputé pour sa bonne table
ces trois hôtels existent depuis des
décennies près de 200 personnes y
travaillaient aujourd'hui tous sont au
chômage et à la dominique les indemnités
n'existe pas
[Musique]
seuls quelques hôtels sont encore
opérationnelles mais dans des conditions
dégradées c'est le cas de fonctionne le
plus grand d'hôtel de la dominique la
moitié des 61 chambres sont hors service
cuisine restaurant et salle de
conférences ont été endommagés et la
piscine est rempli de débris l'heure est
au nettoyage et à la réparation
provisoire
les assurances sont venus pour constater
les dégâts structurels nous dire ce
qu'on doit faire
nous sommes en train de penser à toutes
les options est-ce qu'on répare ou
est-ce qu'on reconstruit entièrement
donc on n'a pas encore pris de décision
on réfléchit toujours
pour l'instant les représentants des
organisations non gouvernementales sont
les seuls clients
le restaurant de l'hôtel est devenu le
qg de ces institutions qui sont venus
apporter leur aide à la dominique
avant l'ouragan maria l'hôtel affiché un
taux de fréquentation de 75% aujourd'hui
selon la direction 50 pouces ont du
personnel est au chômage un chiffre
contesté par les salariés qui estiment
que plus de 60% de leurs collègues n'ont
plus de travail
[Musique]
je suis mère
et ils ont licencié beaucoup de
personnel
mais comme j'étais ici pendant l'ouragan
et durant toute la semaine suivante pour
aider alors ils m'ont gardé
c'est difficile l argent je ne trouve
rien acheté en ville
mais je dois m'accrocher car ma maison
et endommagé
les routes sont dangereuses et je ne
peux pas aller chez moi donc je vois
trouver un logement ville pour garder
mon
le gard way hôtel est situé juste en
face de frontières et la situation est
tout aussi catastrophique
ce treize des trente et une chambre sont
opérationnels le 3 s'est effondré et
tout l'établissement a été inondée selon
un bilan encore provisoire il faudra au
minimum six mois pour remettre l'hôtel
en l'état de fonctionnement en attendant
les propriétaires souhaitent obtenir un
moratoire sur leurs prêts bancaires
on veut un examen financiers et
convenant aux intérêts accumulés
beaucoup plus ont redémarré comme si
c'était un nouveau prêt
donc on peut travailler durant une
période de grâce est entre la tempête et
la reprise d'une activité normale
2 oignons seuls 15 des 33 employés ont
retrouvé leur poste pour ce jeune agent
d'accueil ce travail lui permet de fait
vivre cette personne moi ma mère mon
grand-père mon oncle et sa femme et des
voisins
quand je vois que les entreprises ont dû
fermer qu'il y à beaucoup de gens sans
travail qui doivent compter sur les amis
je suis donc heureux d'avoir du travail
comme ça je peux aider les gens
et pourtant tout allait si bien avant
maria la dominique s'apprêtait à
accueillir la 20e édition du festival
international de musique créole
programmé le dernier week-end d'octobre
2010 est
les billets prévendus ont dû être
remboursés les réservations d'hôtels
sont annulées et les pardons ne feront
plus d'escales la prochaine saison
touristique ne démarrera pas avant fin
[Musique]
sur la route menant au nord de l'île les
dégâts dans les champs cultivés sont
visibles cette cocoteraie a été
complètement ravagé
25% de la population active travaille
dans le secteur agricole or les chansons
dévastait dont les auteurs de sauce
bridard ambo constate les dégâts sur
l'exploitation familiale
36 hectares sur son 21 sont cultivées
depuis plus de 50 ans sur cette pente
brûlé par le vent il y avait un champs
de bananes des pieds de cacao et des
agrumes
le tout était entouré d'une forêt
épaisse qui protégeait les récoltes du
vent et des intempéries
il y a deux semaines si de florissant en
me maintenant il n'y a plus rien à cause
de l'ouragan
donc je vais tout taillé ajouté de
l'engrais récolter d'ici neuf mois
les armes qui ont été détruits servait
de couvent
maintenant on aura beaucoup de vent ce
qui va impacter nos récoltes de nous
n'avons plus de couple
lire williams ne peut toujours pas
accéder à ces champs il doit d'abord
déblayer le chemin une action qui long
terme sont là des autorités il a hâte de
reprendre son activité qui lui
permettait de bien vivre et d'employés
quatre ouvriers il veut connaître les
propositions du gouvernement pour aider
les planteurs sinistrés
j'entends que la vie culturelle
cent-pour-cent anéantie mais je
n'entends pas les projets pour sa
réhabilitation
ça fait trois semaines maintenant et en
attend on n'a même pas accès au champ
j'essaye d'aider avec ça tout seul
mais je ne veux plus attendre je devrais
déjà être en train de replanter mes
ouvriers attendent je ne veux pas les
perdre mais ils sont au bord de la route
peut-être ils vont trouver autre chose
et quand je serai prêt ils seront partis
à
12,40 vidal s'apprête à replanter
séchante de maracuja détruit par
l'ouragan ce fruit a besoin de huit mois
pour mûrir et il souhaite que les
autorités réagissent rapidement car il a
des prêts bancaires à rembourser
je vais replanter des maracuja est
planté 20 des récoltes rapide en dessous
des villes de marcoule jah pour que je
puisse vivre en attendant j'ai dit prêt
bancaire pour mes terres agricoles donc
on doit négocier avec les institutions
financières pour voir comment ils
peuvent m'aider entre temps pour que je
me remette sur pieds
pour l'instant les agriculteurs
récoltent encore tout ce qui est tombé à
terre c'est le cas de ce planteur venus
du nord de l'île pour vendre ses bananes
à bord de sa camionnette dans la
capitale roseaux
la crise mais il faut faire avec tous
tes murs il n'y a plus rien et on ne
peut rien faire dans deux semaines il
n'y aura plus rien dans la terre tout
sera fini
jean hausse la mairie est origine
haïtienne et cultive des terres au nord
de la dominique depuis dix ans il a
encore des légumes racines en terre mais
lorsqu'il aura tous vendus il va falloir
attendre sept mois pour que ses chansons
à nouveau productif et il a besoin
d'argent pour replanter et pour survivre
en attendant la nouvelle récolte
mais j'ai gagné le
manager de la tania de katana de la
banane johnny de lignum mets tout mon
argent est parti
ma maison est écrasée
j'ai besoin de me tuer pour manger
maintenant
ma famille est en haïti mais jusqu'ici
je n'avais pas les appeler
[Musique]
le gouvernement tente de faire face à la
pire catastrophe qu'elle est dominique a
est jamais connu il annonçait qu'il y
aura une longue période de sacrifice les
institutions internationales vont
financer la reconstruction des
infrastructures des écoles et des
hôpitaux
5000 logements anticyclonique seront
construit pour héberger les milliers de
sinistrés pendant six mois les matériaux
de construction seront exemptés de taxes
et le gouvernement a promis de négocier
un délai de grâce auprès des banques
afin de soulager les sinistrés qui ont
des prêts à rembourser la réhabilitation
du secteur agricole est également une
priorité
il faut redémarrer notre économie pour
ne plus être dépendant ou devenir addict
de l'aide alimentaire
tout faux ce n'est pas le développement
qu'on veut
je suis heureux d'annoncer aujourd'hui
que nous avons trouvé des financements
internationaux
et asie un programme de subventions
chaque subvention s'élève à 3000 euros
cette somme sera remise à disposition
des agriculteurs et des petites
entreprises
[Musique]
en attendant le démarrage des programmes
gouvernementaux
c'est chacun pour soi
au bord de la mer les marins pêcheurs
remettent leur embarcation à l'eau
[Musique]
avant la tempête les bateaux avaient été
tirés loin des côtes attaché est remplie
d'eau aujourd'hui à la force des bras
les marins tâche à traves est les 30 ans
à barachet et d'autres débris pour
remettre ce bateau à flot ils ne savent
pas à quel moment la plage sera nettoyée
et les 3000 personnes qui travaillent
dans le secteur de la pêche veulent
reprendre leur activité
c'est la première fois que je mets mon
bateau à lure il ya tous ces débris
c'est difficile pour nous vous avez vous
un congrès nous avons fait et il nous
faut continuer ainsi or nous avons des
bateaux encore plus grand et ce sera
encore plus difficile donc c'est le
premier bateau à l'eau pour l'instant
[Musique]
un autre problème c'est que nous n'avons
pas de glace donc on doit pêcher moins
de poisson parce qu'on n'a pas de glace
et il fait chaud sur le bateau on verra
comment faire mais on ne pourra pas
rester longtemps en mer à cause de ce
problème d'habitude nous on a des
glaciers et empêche avec la glace
c'est donc lentement et péniblement
qu'elle a dû miniter ses habitants vent
surmonté les obstacles et les défis
imposés par le rpt ago mari à la nuit du
18 septembre 2010 est l'objectif du
gouvernement est de reconstruire la dnic
selon les critères de développement
durable
un modèle de résilience face aux
changements climatiques
chaque